one of the organizations that was
instructing Twitter on which accounts to
censor on various covid content stories
including criticism of lockdowns
including questions around the vaccine
efficacy came from this organization
public good projects this was an
organization that was fully funded by
the vaccine makers the biotech
Innovation organization that's the lobby
group that represents moderna and Pfizer
they provided a special Grant to these
disinformation researchers they
organized this this project and they had
backdoor access telling Twitter they
would send a weekly update of which
Twitter accounts should be censored
which of them should be Shadow banned
including some very major accounts like
Zero Hedge so big Pharma were telling
social media to censor specific people
about the vaccine that's right